well another woman has come forward and
says Herschel Walker paid for one of my
abortions as well and the question we
have at this time is does this even
matter to the very same Republican
voters who say abortion is the most
important issue to them background on
this some weeks ago uh Georgia
Republican Senate candidate Herschel
Walker had a woman come forward and say
hey you know what he publicly says no
exceptions for abortion nothing nothing
nothing always against it because it's
murder but he urged me to get and paid
for an abortion for me some years ago
and then later when he got me pregnant
again he tried to get me to have another
abortion but that time I refused and he
is the father of one of my children this
was one woman Herschel Walker denied it
with very little credibility admitting
that yes he did send a check to the
woman but it was for the kid they had
together even though he sent the check
years before that kid was born
completely unbelievable any sensible
person looks at the facts and says
of course Herschel Walker paid for This
Woman's abortion it's very very clear
another woman has now come forward and
said Herschel Walker impregnated me and
also
urged me to get and paid for an abortion
that woman known currently as Jane Doe
is represented by attorney Gloria Allred
and uh let's listen to a little bit of
the press conference yesterday this is
again a second woman
says that Mr Walker gave her cash to pay
for the abortion
and that she went to a clinic in Dallas
Texas
however while she was at the clinic
she became overwhelmed with emotion
she could not go through with it and she
left the clinic in tears
when Mr Walker called that night our
client told him what had happened and
that she had not gone through with the
abortion
he was upset
he pressured her to go back to the
clinic with him the next day to go
through with the abortion
the following day
Mr Walker drove her to the clinic
and waited in the parking lot for hours
until the abortion was completed and she
came out
then he drove her to the pharmacy
to pick up medications and supplies as
prescribed
and then he drove her home
in the days following the abortion Mr
Walker began to distance himself from
our client she was very distraught
because she felt that Mr Walker had
pressured her into having an abortion
she left Dallas after she moved out of
Dallas Mr Walker sent our client a note
apologizing for what he had put her
through
as you will hear from my client Jane Doe
she has come forward at this time
because she feels that it's important
that the truth comes out so you get the
sense and the picture of what's going on
here there is another moment at which
Gloria Allred presents what is alleged
to be a photo of Herschel Walker in the
bed of Jane Doe's hotel room this is a
photo
of Herschel Walker
our clients hotel room
on the bed
again this is Minnesota
okay and then we also heard by voice
from the woman herself talking about
what happened and making it clear that
she's a trump voter this is not
political for her
I am a registered independent
and I voted for Donald Trump in both
elections
I do not believe
that Herschel is morally fit
to be a U.S senator that's clear
and that is the reason why I am speaking
up
and providing proof so the question of
course is is this going to matter when
we look at the polling in this race it
is a dead Heat
half a point on average separates
Raphael Warnock the incumbent Democratic
senator and Herschel Walker
Walker is a liar
Walker is incompetent
Walker has no business being even in
this race but because of what has
happened to this country
because of what has happened to the
Georgia Republican electorate
Herschel Walker may be the next senator
from Georgia which is an incredible
incredible thing if you vote in Georgia
there are just days to go 12 days right
is that where we are let me see here
seven
and then yeah 12 days
with 12 days to go
we've got to do everything we can to
prevent a dangerously unqualified
individual from becoming the next
senator from Georgia let's go now to
Herschel Walker's reactions
something in your home that you use
every day contributes to deforestation
and climate change and that's toilet
paper in the U.S alone over 30 million
trees each year are required to meet
toilet paper demands contributing to
deforestation soil erosion devastating
loss of biodiversity our sponsor real
paper makes sustainable toilet paper
that is 100 made from bamboo a bamboo
stock keeps growing it can be harvested
forever it means that the soil and the
ecosystem aren't disrupted no carbon
removing trees are cut down the paper
industry has a massive effect on
deforestation and climate change but you
alone using bamboo toilet paper can make
a positive impact because for the toilet
paper that just one American uses in
their lifetime hundreds of trees are
required put an end to that right now
with real paper the best part is the
stuff is really great it's just normal
Soft toilet paper real paper loves the
David Pacman show they're giving my
audience 30 off your first order and
free shipping when you go to
realpaper.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below